The general experience and David Allan
Coe,
did you know we did our song,
our set and then he played and he was
onstage and he performed a song my mom
wrote called storms never last,
so my mom's over on the side of the
stage and we were talking to.
My mom were watching it and he's singing
it with his wife and stuff.
The next night I'm opening up for him
and he goes on stage and he goes,
last night,
Jessi colter was right in the front row
when I sang the song and my wife and she
was crying and like I'm sitting there
going,
I was here and she was not crying.
She was standing on the front row.
Right,
right.
My mom just kilder road.
This song,
storms,
everlast teasing and,
and that's his character.
That's who he is.
All I'm saying here with like I'm as
forgiving about him lying to the
audience because that is what he's doing
at the moment.
It's his.
I could sit there and go,
you know what?
You're lying.
I'm going to take you in the back.
We're going to talk.
I'm going to tell this audience tomorrow
night.
He's a liar.
He's a piece of shit.
Fuck him.
I'm not going to do that because it's
David Alcoa is,
but you just did it on the show,
which is a much larger audience and
millions of pieces of shit.
I'm just saying character.
Well,
why would I do that to him?
Because it's like,
you know,
I just feel like,
look man,
the Times that I met Alex at times I've
been around him.
Yeah man,
his Gig is this and he got called out
for a specific thing.
Yes.
It involved the lives of children and
everything that I understand that I'm
not.
I'm not at all sympathizing for the
family or for him versus those families,
but I'm just saying,
I just think that like at the moment
everything is so hot with this and it's,
it's kind of exhausting and it's the
Internet is the reason for it and in my
opinion,
because I think that like all of the
years that have come along,
the mass amount of people that have
migrated to social media,
the way that the integrated
conversations happened,
the way that that stuff ends up on the
news now,
like aol chat rooms in fucking 1998.
That shit did not end up on CNN.
People were not listening to those.
The,
the,
the best to get the closest you could
get to fucking tv was to catch a
Predator when,
when you were on that,
at that time,
you know,
and I feel like at this point in time
people need again,
not those families,
their lawsuit.
That's fine,
that's,
that's their thing.
But,
but I just feel like people need to
lighten up a little bit in the sense of.
I just think that the social media thing
is very hazardous and I think that
people's faith in all of it,
it doesn't have to do with,
with fake news and it doesn't have to do
with Russian bots and all this shit.
I just think that like Alex Jones is a
casualty because he's always been that.
What do you mean by another really odd
comic Davidson?
Sarah's story is he always told me when
you're on the road,
don't read from your current book.
Always read from the next four pieces to
way of road testing the stories
and finding out which ones work and
should go into the next book.
And in doing so,
he was telling this story about being in
this,
uh,
this forensic,
a laboratory isn't an,
as an autopsy was taking place.
And this autopsy table was adjacent to
this huge indoor window that separated
the autopsy suite from this lunch room
and in the lunch room where the rest of
the,
uh,
the forensic staff,
they're all eating their lunches.
They all had tuna sandwiches and cans of
coke and barbecued potato chips.
And they were watching through the
window as this absolutely perfect.
Twelve year old boy was being autopsied
and just hours before at this kid,
like two hours before this kid had been
riding his bicycle,
he'd fallen over.
He'd hit his head on the curb.
And now two hours later he was dead and
dead without almost a scratch on him.
Just this perfect naked dead 12 year old
boy on the autopsy table.
And as he that the technicians eating
their lunch,
watching it through a window that they
watch as the,
uh,
as the pathologist in sizes around the
top of the kid's face at the top of the
forehead,
the hairline,
and then peels the face down,
like peeling an orange peels the entire
face off of the skull of this little boy
and leaves the face around the neck like
a mask,
like a rubber mask.
And this exposes this liver colored dark
red musculature of the child's
underlying face.
And this one guy watching it with a
mouthful of tuna sandwich,
he points this out and he says,
see that?
That there,
that's the color of red that I want to
paint our rec room.
Holy Shit,
and once the data has told that story in
front of 600 people,
it was dead silent and you could hear
people weeping.
People were crying and they were hating
David's sit doris in that moment and so
I had to laugh.
I laughed really loud,
like a donkey and it was amazing how the
hatred in that auditorium swung from
hating David,
who they did not want to hate to hating
this jackass over here who was actually
laughing and so I threw myself on the
sword for David and that story never
went in any book and like I said,
you can do that.
And philosophers like arguing and
debating the meaning of things.
For me,
it's harder.
People are using the word.
That's the meaning.
I concede that.
Well,
we can see why I don't call myself an
atheist.
It's why you can look up the dictionary
definition of atheist and a kind of
applies
to me,
but what is the definition of atheist in
practice?
It is what leading atheists do and it's
their conduct and it's their behaviors,
what they say,
and it's,
it's,
it's their attitudes that is what an
atheist is today because they're the
most visible exemplars of that word and
most of their conduct either don't agree
with or simply don't engage in what
don't you agree with?
I don't debate religious people and tell
them they're idiots.
I don't know.
That doesn't work.
It's missing whether or not it works and
it's just not.
It's not in me to do that.
I don't purge myself of words that have
religious foundations in them.
I once in my facebook,
I had a friend going up in orbit to
repair the Hubble Telescope,
one of the astronauts and I said,
uh,
Godspeed.
And then I gave the astronauts name
people wrote in,
in the threads that I thought you were
an atheist.
How could you say Godspeed and atheist
got angry with me and I said,
okay.
First of all,
this phrase is deeply historical in the
space program.
When John Glenn was launched,
the headline was Godspeed John Glenn.
Every mission where we send human beings
into space.
Somewhere there is that reference in the
NASA fancy word means I'll tell you,
I'll tell you what it means.
Please do
so.
Oh,
by the way,
I'll get to that in just one minute.
The atheist who are arguing that I was
using Godspeed as a phrase,
they all have used the phrase goodbye
having to see you later.
Goodbye.
What does that word come from?
It's from God.
Be With you.
It's a contraction of those three words.
Oh,
and why would you say this?
You would say this to someone leaving
the city wall where it's dangerous.
Okay.
Back when you had city states,
you're going to,
you,
you're a good God.
Be With you to bring protection for you.
Between one city.
One of the people who's asking,
asked me to have pictures of my other
dogs.
They're actually both passed away now.
I had to put them both down.
Both your bull mastiffs stiff in the
English of the English bulldog.
She mixed.
They were,
uh,
they were both 13 years old and I'm.
Johnny couldn't walk anymore.
It was,
it was really rough
the last few days of his life.
Um,
I would,
uh,
try to bring them in for dinner and when
I would try to bring them in,
he literally couldn't make,
it was a small yard where he was at,
but we're talking about like,
you know,
15 yards.
He couldn't make it 15 yards to the
house.
He will take a couple steps and his body
would shake and he'd take a couple of
steps and he was just sleeping all day
and he was also having a really hard
time shifting and he would occasionally
shit in the house,
like he couldn't hold his bowels and he
couldn't go outside when he wanted to
look at,
you'd see them trying.
But his,
his body was so old from massive 13
years old,
his crazy old,
like a lot of them die at like eight or
nine and he was 13 and he was sweet,
sweet dog up until the end.
But he just,
he was,
you know,
he was suffering.
It was,
it was hard.
It's hard when you know them when
they're a puppy and then 10 years later,
like you're kind of the same and they're
not men,
they're gone.
You know.
So I think about that with Marshall
because he's only a year and a half and
he's so full of life and he's so fun.
He's so silly and playful and happy.
I'm like,
man,
there's going to be a day where
Marshall's,
this old old,
old dog and I'm going to have to put him
down to,
you know,
it was depressing and the other one,
brutus,
the Shiba Inu English bulldog mix.
He was better than Johnny for a long
time.
Still I've known for the last two years
that they didn't have much time left.
You know,
they were,
they were both struggling hard.
But Brutus took a real hard turn over
the last few months where he wouldn't
even come in.
Like I tried to get them to come in my
body,
you want to eat.
I try to put a little food in front of
his face and he would try to stand up
and his legs would be shaken.
And it's just so hard,
man.
It's so hard watching them fade away,
you know?
And then also watching them suffer,
you know,
a lot the last,
the last days where you have to decide
where,
you know,
me and my wife had to have conversations
like,
look,
we have to do something like this,
like one day we're going to come home,
it's going to be a dead dog.
And it's not like they're having a good
time.
Like this is a,
this is a horrible suffering slow
demise.
So did you have someone come to the
house?
When did you take them?
Yeah,
it was rough,
dude.
That's rough.
Just ask yourself what problems do I
have right now?
But genuinely like problems.
And the answer may not always be zero,
but it's usually surprisingly small when
you think about the immediate,
you know,
not just the base level of Maslow's
hierarchy,
right?
Like if that's taken care of,
usually it's like,
oh I don't know.
There are things that are ongoing things
to figure out,
but like things that you could define as
a problem and then just kind of staying
in that space of like,
you know,
like a control issue.
Like what's a real issue where there's
like immediacy,
like you know,
and,
and when,
when there are real problems,
you know,
a lot of times you,
you handle it well,
like instinctually the things like a lot
of times people get caught in those
intense situations like,
you know,
like they can handle like real problems.
It's the anticipation of problems and
the anticipation of solutions that bass.
What drives you.
Crazy.
Very good point.
Yeah.
That's a very good point.
A lot of times real problems.
They also sort of enlightened you to the
fact that most of the time your problems
are bullshit.
You know,
you break your leg,
you're,
oh,
that's an immediate.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so just staying in the space of
like,
you know,
all right,
I can,
you're in a control center.
You Go,
you know.